welcome to my new latest dojo
it's the smallest one I've ever built
and hopefully it will hold around 10
people to train
the purpose of it is for me to make
these YouTube films that I've been
making out since covert arrived and due
to the drop in numbers around the world
in the classes
just for the decline of most martial
arts but
in Aikido there's I didn't feel the need
to build a large Dojo again
I hope this Dojo will give people
detailed information
and if they do wish to travel from
around the world to Stay With Me
and be my student for a short period of
time
or just a day then hopefully this will
suffice and uh
be a place where they can learn in
advance
I'll just show you around the dojo
and uh
give you jobs
acquaintance yourself
with the dojo
and how it looks
today is the first day that I've decided
to
come into the dojo as a way just
completed it
and it's been completed
with the view that um
will be using it very soon
I'll take you back
and go from the Showman
to the other way
so that you get chance to see
the area
my certificates I've gained over the
years
ending with these at the end here these
two from China when I
when there to do my tai chi
demonstrations
in front of a large crowd and eventually
four million TV viewers
obviously a very nervous time but I'm
pleased to say that I enjoyed my time
there and my master Mr Faye
so we're complementing the Aikido
I think doing Tai Chi and yoga what will
also be taking part of within this dojo
I'm hoping that everybody will bet
benefit and make their well-being become
much better
than Perhaps it is today
I did have a a green to Tammy before
but we decided after
many many years possibly 30 years of
keeping it
we would upgrade to a nice new blue one
thank you for your time
and yes I hope in the future will become
a place where many will study and learn
thank you